Hi, I'm Eric Voss and [star] [wars] [episode] [eight] the last Jedi has his first teaser trailer, and yeah
while
It's more of a teaser giving us a few cryptic clues
hinting at what the movie will be about, the last Jedi still looks great!
Luke Skywalker speaks guys sure he's
Breaking our hearts
by telling
Us that Jedi have to end
But you know at least the guys talking baby steps guy and this teaser was really well crafted with a few little
Easter eggs throughout that connect the last Jedi to the rest of the star wars universe maybe some references to the eu as well
So I'm going [to] dive deep and break down everything in this trailer frame by frame
And point out a few things that you might have missed so let's get started
[Luke Skywalker] Breath...
[Luke Skywalker] Just, Breath...
[Luke Skywalker] Now, Reach Out...
Luke Skywalker] What do you see?
[Distant Leia Organa Voice] Help me Obi-Wan...
[Rey] Light...
I think this teaser really wants us to feel that same excitement that we felt leading up to the force awakens because this whole opening
Surprise is definitely meant to reflect the one that started [the] first force awakens teaser
there's a wide shot of a vast void as the music builds up tension until
orchestral punch with a sweaty panicked out of breath hero jumping into frame
So the idea is that the last Jedi will have that same kind of suspense and surprise?
That the Force Awakens had also this music with the strings and cell chimes leaving us in this mysterious state of unrest
Sounds very similar to the opening notes of the second Force awakens trailer now Rey's
Expression here seems like she just came out of a dream or a vision or something maybe another force vision like the one she experienced
in Force Awakens and the voice of Luke Skywalker instructs,
"Breath"
Suggesting a big part of this movie will be him training her the way another hermit [Yoda] trained him in The Empire Strikes Back
We also see these beautiful wide shots of Ach-To which if you didn't know is a real island called [Skellig] [Michael]
on the Southwestern Coast of Ireland
It's actually the location of an ancient
Christian monastery and it's a protected historical site and over this we hear new music come in, the Force Theme
[Luke skywalker], "Breath." (Theme plays over words)
So this Force Theme is actually the [first] of a few different musical themes that this trailer all weaves together, okay?
So after more awesome geo-porn of Ach-To, and Rey looking out at the crashing waves
We hear Luke instructing her to "reach out."
And there's this shot of Rey's hand levitating rocks
Which was rumored to be part of the footage showed to Disney investors last month?
So it seems like Rey's training will follow Luke's even more closely remember yoda made him levitate rocks to actually think this
Levitation training will end with rays same hand brakes another rock in that opening shot and then after Luke whispers
the music shifts again
This is Ray's theme composed by John Williams for the Force Awakens
To get this shot of the back of general Leia Organa. She's staring at this hologram Star map
But let's look closely at this location, the window suggests that this is the bridge of a battleship
And I'm pretty sure that's admiral ackbar in the background there
So this could be his mon calamari
Flagship Home One. And, if you listened really closely with [the] part they very subtly mixed in the audio [of] Leia's lines from the very first Star Wars chapter a new hope
[Leia]: "Help me Obi-Wan Kenobi, you"re my only hope."
That plea for help from Leia was Luke's first sight of his sister and this teaser is repurposing that moment to Establish Luke's
remaining force connection with the sister even though his exile had made her distant and faded in his memory and by
Calling this image light Ray is suggesting that of all the different parts of the force that she could be reaching out to
Leia Represents the one remaining light part of it, and we see the other side of the force as we move on to the next section
[Darth Vader's breathing]
[Obi- Wan voice over] "Sedused by the dark side
[Rey]: "Darkness."
So this next part shifts over to the dark side
There's this serious shot of what looks like the crushed helmet of Kylo Ren, now you can see a similar pattern on this piece here
So what happened here? Whatever this is it's a mess
There's a piece of a helmet that's still smoking so this could be the ruins of Starkiller base even [though]
I'm pretty sure it was completely wiped out or slightly more likely it could be
Kylos ship as the angrily retreats from that defeat
And it's interesting to see Kylo's destroyed helmet
Which is another echo from the Force Awakens trailer which
included a shot of kylo
Looking at Darth Vader's destroyed mask. Now, Kylo modeled his helmet to show respect and admiration for his grandfather
So I think this image here is meant [to] [tie] into that family connection
Also again the audio plays into this with the missable sound of vader's iconic breathing
Also, you can just barely make out the voice of Obi-Wan Kenobi as he tells Luke about Anakin's fall
Vader was seduced by the dark side of the force
and right before Rey labels this side the force, "Darkness",
we hear the new music theme that this trailer shifts into
This is John Williams's Kylo Ren theme from the Force Awakens
Alright let's move on
The balance
[Luke Skywalker] "It's so much bigger."
Okay, so now that Rey has reached out to the light side of the force and the dark side this third image takes us somewhere
She calles
And the imagery of what we see here is a literal balance of light and dark
a beam of light streaking through the dark Surroundings.
Now, This is a small bookshelf
And the wall behind it looks like the roots of a tree now in past star wars videos that we've done
We've talked about how in the expanded universe novel shattered Empire Luke
Skywalker tracks down two force sensitive trees that once grew under the Jedi temple in Khorasan and one of those trees gets planted in the
Home of Poe Dameron which might explain why he's such a great pilot Meanwhile
Maybe the other force tree could be part of the roots that we're seeing here like luke planted it on this island now
I doubt that The Last Jedi I will bring in that EU theory into this movie
But it could be a reference to it.
Now, so what exactly are these books when Rey looks at one of the pages
We see this symbol. This is a symbol of the Jedi order
I've always loved this image, especially how it uses a lightsaber [flair] imagery from that original Star Wars poster
And I'm guessing that Luke was able to recover all these [old] texts from around the galaxy like maybe in the ruins of that Jedi
Temple and under this you can just barely hear the voice of yoda from Empire strikes back its energy
surrounds us, and binds us
There's also the sound of a lightsaber powering up now this balance that they refer to
Between light and dark sides of the Force has been kind of a classic dualism at the heart of the entire Star Wars Saga
But what luke says here suggests that the last Jedi will go much deeper than this conflict
So there's a few ways that we can interpret Luke's words here some of them are sexual so let's just ignore those for now
I said ignore!
they're also a few things in the expanded universe that could help explain this one is the concept of
Grey Jedi or Grey Knights now a Grey Jedi is a Jedi who walks the line between
The light and the dark side of the Force without surrendering to the dark side it also refers to Jedi who
distance themselves from the Jedi High Council and operate outside of the Jedi code and one example the character Jolee Bindo from the knights of
the old Republic game there's also been some debate over whether Qui-gon Jinn was a Grey Jedi then again some people at the
Lucasfilm story group have
Rejected this idea saying that the dark side isn't meant to give a Jedi edge or make him more of a badass
It's meant to be a binary opposite with a real cost but still I could see how this idea
Influences where Luke is at right now like he saw how there was still good in his father even after he surrendered to the dark
Side and later his attempts to bring back the old
dogmatic Jedi order in Traditions
Led to the disaster of his nephew Ben becoming Kylo ren so just like how the color of Luke's clothes
gradually changed throughout the films starting white but then becoming
Increasingly Darker as we became closer to his father and then back to these grey mid-tones
Maybe the concept of the grey Jedi is influencing luke subconsciously in his exile like it could just be his
Experiences have led luke to seeing things not in black and white with the force, but more in shades of grey
Okay, I didn't say 50 shades of grey the other possible EU influence on Luke here comes from the figure Bendu from Star [Wars]
Rebels so Bendu is a massive ancient moose looking creature with camouflagey bark like skin
He's definitely force sensitive
And it can do a lot of things that Jedi can't even do but he claims to be neither light nor dark
But in the middle actually the word Bendu is a deep throwback to George Lucas's
original script for a new hope where the original name for
Jedi was Jedi Bendu and some people are suggesting
That so much bigger could be referring to Bendu massive size
And that's a surface behind the bookshelf is Bendu bark skin,
but.. no.   I'm really leaning against Bendu or grey Jedi turning up in this movie literally
But I do think the philosophy behind them is true for luke like the old simple duality of the star Wars Saga
Isn't true for him anymore and before I move on this not of Rey training with Luke's lightsaber on the cliffside features a few interestingly
Shaped Rock formations like one it's a camera pans around the cliffs in another next to Rey like these might just be boulders
But they definitely look human shapes right like I'm wondering if the one next to Rey will end up being
Some kind of monument that luke made in the shape of obi-wan or anakin or yoda or just some boulder, let's move
Okay, so here the teaser kicks in a gear first are these shots of I'm guessing resistant fighters as they speed across this
Remote planet called Crait, and they're flying towards first order walkers
and those have been nicknamed gorilla Walkers since they're
larger with bigger sturdier front arms firmly
Planted in the ground and probably because we're too eager to shoot them and RIP Harambe now what are these fighters doing?
First I thought they were releasing plumes of red smoke like Skywriter flames, but no
They're actually using these anchors to scrape the ground kicking up this bright red soil now
I'm not sure exactly why they're doing it
but my guess is that they're kicking up dirt as a
smokescreen
Effect like maybe making it harder for the walkers to target them and this red color is such an interesting visual choice for a planet
In a star wars movie like we don't normally seen non-earthy colors or places that couldn't possibly
Exist somewhere on Earth and Brian Johnson said that Crait is the location of an old rebel base where red mineral
Sand is covered in a white dusty salt surface
so maybe it is red is caused by
oxidized
rusted Metal
Particles in the soil we also get this quick shot of Finn who looks like he's still recovering in some kind of medical Pod remember
He left his fight with Kylo ren pretty messed up
And in case we were wondering someone actually
Translated the Aurebesh letters on the screen there, and while some of it just translated to nonsense the word here means stable
So I guess he's okay also look at the corners of the frame that flashing blue light kind of looks like hyperspace to me
So I know that sounds crazy
But maybe Finn is being sent through hyperspace in his own portable medical escape Pod which might explain why he has this
Additional shell over his body which would like to protect them from turbulence now
I don't know if that's even possible with star Wars technology like this Pod would need its own hyper drive, right?
seems excessive like I can buy interstellar escape pods for Kryptonians
but less
So for cash-strapped resistant soldiers but still that could mean that wherever finn was recovering ended up under attack so that his body had to be
Hastily sent off like this
and I'm guessing that attack is what we're seeing in these next few shots with Poe and
BB-8, there's an explosion and a resistance hangar that nearly engulfs Poe's Black x-Wing
and if you look over to the left
Those two engine and belongs to an A-wing which we get a quick glimpse of later on in this teaser, but let's move on
I only know one truth
So here. There's more action with the millennium Falcon in a dogfight with tie fighters
And I'm interested to see who's piloting the Falcon here considering it won't be
Han so I don't know if this means ray will be taking the wheel now or chewy or
Maybe we'll get a little cameo from Mr.. Billy. Dee Williams now
I know they said Lando wouldn't be in this movie
but come on my kid can dream and after shots of Rey running with Luke's lightsaber and
Kylo ren menacingly twisting his same blade which I guess he still has along with that scar that Ray gave them we get this
interesting shot of Luke and R2-D2
Looking at this burning structure actually this shot looks like it's part of that same
mystery seen that Rey saw in her force vision and that burning building
Looks a lot like a jedi temple with a central pyramid so we're probably going to see this event in the last Jedi
Possibly a flashback to when Kylo turned on Luke
I also like how this visual parallels luke returning home to find another
Flaming pile of Ashes and the shape of his aunt and uncle in a new hope and I really hope luke as homeowners insurance really
Though I think these tragic homecomings are meant to be connected to characterize luke as a wanderer
Disconnected from his home
And then in a different fiery location we get a quick shot of captain Phasma as she marches in with First-order soldiers
I feel like this could be that same resistance hangar after the attack and Phasma has arrived probably in search of that traitorous
FN-2187 who forced her inside a trash compactor at Starkiller base
There's also some quick
But amazing space battle shots with these new looking
Resistance Frigates forming a line at X-wings and tie fighters take each other out
There's also a quick shot of an a-wing and let's move on to this final part
[Luke Skywaker]: 'It;s time for the Jedi..
to end."
Wow, okay? I don't know about you, but I was like oooh time for the Jedi to...
What return wait that's already a movie title?
to kick some ass party down?
[Luke Skywalker]: "-To end."
What? Luke you're breaking my heart. Daisy Ridley actually described raised sense of disappointment here
She said Ray has a certain expectation as to what she might be getting from Luke
It's difficult when you meet your heroes
So it sounds [like] when this movie picks back up on that shot with ray returning Luke's lightsaber to him his reaction might be
Something more like sorry kid ain't the Jedi that I used to be
Get off my Island
Of course this all makes sense because this is the last Jedi
But now the teaser has given us more context to what that means for luke this perennial
Conflict within the forest with the light Jedi on one side and the dark sit on the [other]
hasn't really given him the balance or answers that he's been seeking and I think he's
suggesting here that in order to end the Sith, the Jedi must also end and that
Involves moving Beyond the old dogma of the Jedi order into a more complex
Pluralistic view of the Force which this final shot reflects showing luke exiting the cave
Entering a more enlightened world okay, so those are all the things that I noticed in its first teaser for the last Jedi
But I'm sure we'll see even more footage and set photos in the coming months that will clear a lot of [this] stuff up along
With the rest of the cast like chewy and C3-PO and Rose Kelly Marie trans characters and hopefully snoke
But come on guys snoke is everyone right isn't that what the theory is?
We do a ton of star wars coverage actually did a super in-depth rogue one breakdown that you should go check out if you haven't
Already and if you like this video please hit like and subscribe to new Rock stars and share this video around you can also contribute
To us on Patreon thanks so much to all of our current patrons you guys are all great
especially
Wilhelmina Ebbesen you can hit me up on Twitter at Ea box with any thoughts or predictions you have on the last Jedi or follow
New Rock stars on Twitter at new Rock Stars for updates on our videos alright. Thanks for watching, bye!